la fédération française a organisé ce
vendredi 3 février une cérémonie au
vélodrome nationale objectif rendre
hommage aux acteurs politiques saint
quentinois qui on devrait pour la
construction de la structure
michel laugier président de saint
quentin en yvelines ainsi que son
prédécesseur robert cadalbert et
l'ancien vice président yves macheboeuf
ont reçu la médaille d'or des mains du
président de la ffc david lappartient
la médaille d'or est une médaille très
symbolique il n'en ai remis que 5 par an
donc ça renforce le poids et la valeur
de cette médaille et c'est important que
je puisse honorer parce que c'est quand
même moi qui ai travaillé avec eux
recevoir la médaille d'or de la
fédération française de cyclisme
c'était l'odeur d'honneur qui pour moi
illustre nom laisse tissement que j'ai
pu faire pour l'arrivée de la fédération
la construction du vélodrome c'est une
marque qui me va droit au coeur parce
que effectivement pour nous à saint
quentin en yvelines
l'arrivée de la fédération et donc la
construction d'un vélodrome était
effectivement dix ans de travail pour
réaliser ce projet les discussions ont
été âpres
les premières réunions ont eu lieu au
début des années 2000 malgré l'échec de
la candidature de paris aux jo de 2012
le projet est maintenu et officiellement
lancé en 2009 pour une livraison en
janvier 2014
coût global des travaux 74 millions
d'euros en partenariat public privé
c'est jamais évident de sortir des
équipements publics de ce niveau là en
plus on arrive avec des périodes comme
ans est difficile et donc il fallait
arriver à bien montrer que globalement
le projet tel qu'il était ficelé tenait
la route tant sur l'aspect de la
réussite sportive mais aussi de son
équilibre avec les manifestations qu'on
pouvait y faire et en même temps prendre
la globalité des besoins que ce soit
pour la fédération mais aussi pour le
territoire
mais la plus belle récompense pour est
arrivé le 13 septembre prochain avec la
désignation de la ville hôte pour les jo
de 2024
si le dossier parisien est retenu le
vélodrome à coeur à cette occasion les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste et le bmx